we all have this inherent fear of water
and the idea of bringing that fear right
into our own backyard it's very exciting
for us everyone's had that feeling of
like what's in the pool and I love the
what if of
that what should be a safe body of water
it doesn't feel safe especially when
you're by yourself especially at
night there is a vulnerability in water
even if you are confident swimmer it is
scary
ehy in water we become prey again really
quickly it's a scary movie idea that's
always been in the back of my head I
used to do night swims myself I always
think that when I come up for air I may
see a figure standing on the edge of my
swimming
[Music]
pool night swim was always about how I
felt when I was a kid in a pool by
myself
and just being absolutely convinced that
there was something beneath me a lot of
people share that
fear the water really it's stronger than
you it's not a safe
environment you're going to think twice
about jumping in your swimming pool
there's no doubt about
it
I